OF A RUSSIAN BOUNTY SITUATION
THAT THEY SAID ISN’T
CORROBORATED.
LET’S BRING IN KEVIN MCCARTHY
MINORITY LEADER.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR JOINING
US, LEADER MCCARTHY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW THIS STORY
IS GOING, CHUCK SCHUMER SAYS
WHAT’S WORSE, NOT KNOWING OR
KNOWING AND NOT DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
HOW DO YOU ANSWER?
>> WELL I THINK WHAT’S WORSE IS
WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER IS PLAYING
INTO.
HE’S PLAYING POLITICS WITH
AMERICAN LIVES BY SAYING WHAT
HE’S SAYING.
WE ALL KNOW THAT RUSSIA IS
DANGEROUS TO AMERICA.
THAT’S WHY THIS ADMINISTRATION,
THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION CHANGED
FROM THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION OF
A RESETTING.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID WAS GAVE
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WAS
ALSO PUT SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING
EVERYTHING HE DID TO PROTECT OUR
AMERICAN TROOPS, BUT THE IDEA OF
LEAKING INFORMATION, NOT EVEN
KNOWING WHETHER IT’S TRUE OR
NOT, IN THE PROCESS, AND
PLAYING IT OUT IN POLITICS IS
DANGEROUS TO ALL AMERICANS WHO
SERVE IN OUR MILITARY ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS NOT A PLACE FOR THIS.
CHUCK SCHUMER IS PART OF THE
GANG AS I AM MYSELF AND THIS
IS NOT THE WAY WE SHOULD
HANDLE THE SITUATION OR
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND PLAY
IT OUT INTO POLITICS.
STEVE: IT CERTAINLY IS NOT
ILLEGAL FOR THE NEW YORK TIMES
TO PRINT THE STORY, AND
EVERYBODY HAS PICKED IT UP BUT
IT IS ILLEGAL WHOEVER INSIDE
GOVERNMENT DID LEAK IT TO THE
NEW YORK TIMES, ESSENTIALLY
BUT ULTIMATELY, LET’S SAY IT IS
TRUE, LEADER MCCARTHY AND RUSSIA
DID PAY AND I KNOW THERE’S SOME
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER OR  NOT A
CAR BOMBING IN APRIL OF 2019
RESULTED IN THE DEATHS OF
THREE MARINES.
ULTIMATELY, IF IT DID HAPPEN,
AND RUSSIA DID PAY TO HAVE
AMERICANS KILLED WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO TO RUSSIA?
>> WELL THERE BE MANY OPTIONS
OF WHAT WE COULD DO TO RUSSIA.
THE ONE THING YOU DO HAVE TO
FIND RIGHT NOW IS FIND OUT IF IT
IS TRUE.
I KNOW INDIVIDUALS ARE SAYING
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS ON BOTH
SIDES.
LET’S GET ALL OF THE INFORMATION
AND LET’S NOT PLAY THIS OUT INTO
THE PUBLIC.
LET’S GET THE REAL INFORMATION
SO THOSE ON HAND CAN DO THE
ACTIONS THAT WE NEED TO HOLD
BACK, BUT THE ONE THING I DO
KNOW THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
THOUGH, STRONGER SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA, BY ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT, STANDS UP TO HIM,
ALSO GIVING UKRAINE WEAPONS
WHERE OBAMA WOULD ONLY GIVE THEM
BLANKETS.
LET’S HANDLE THIS IN THE MANNER
IN WHICH WE SHOULD MAKING SURE
WE’RE PROTECTING OUR TROOPS
FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT
REGARDLESS WHOEVER LOOKS AT
AMERICAN TROOPS THAT THEY WILL
HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR ANY
ACTIONS THAT THEY GO AFTER.
AINSLEY: SO CONGRESSMAN, TALKING
TO A FRIEND YESTERDAY IN GEORGIA
, AND SHE WAS ON THE
BEACH AND ALL THEIR KIDS
WITH ALL THE KIDS AND THEY HAVE
TO WEAR MASKS AND SHE SAID
THEY’RE BURNING UP HOT BUT THEY
ARE REQUIRING IT AND EVEN THE
LITTLE ONES, THE LITTLE
THREE-YEAR-OLD HAS TO WEAR A
MASK AND IT’S ANNOYING BUT SHE
WANTS TO STAY SAFE.
IN YOUR HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THEY ARE DOING THE SAME THING.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY CLOSING THE
BEACHES IN SOME PARTS OF
YOUR STATE FOR THE JULY 4TH
WEEKEND SHUTTING DOWN BARS NOW
AND MANDATING THE MASKS BECAUSE
WE’RE SEEING A RISE IN CASES.
WHAT’S YOUR ADVICE TO YOUR HOME
STATE?
>> WELL FOR MY HOME STATE I DO
BELIEVE IN WEARING MASKS.
I DO NOT WANT TO SHUT THE
ECONOMY BACK DOWN.
EVERY DAY WE LEARN MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
WHAT WE’RE LEARNING NOW IS IT’S
NOT BEING PASSED BAYOU TENSE ILL
S AND OTHERS WHAT WE CAUGHT
EARLY.
IT’S ACTUALLY THE DROPLETS FROM
INDIVIDUALS TO ANOTHER ONE, SO
WEARING A MASK, SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCHING YOUR
FACE AND WASHING YOUR HANDS IS A
WAY WE CAN CONTINUE THE ECONOMY
OPENING UP.
IN MY HOME COMMUNITY IT’S NOT
THE BARS AS MUCH THAT IS PASSING
FROM THE HEALTH COMMUNITY, IT’S
FROM WITHIN THEIR OWN HOMES SO
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
BRIAN:  YEAH SHELTER IN PLACE IS
NOT GOING TO FLY ANY MORE, BUT
LET’S ADD TO THIS.
WE GET A LOT OF THIS STAT BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE DEATHS IN THIS
COUNTRY, EVEN TWO WEEKS AGO
, 11% OF ALL DEATHS WERE DUE
TO COVID-19.
NOW, EVEN THOUGH THE CASES ARE
GOING UP, IT GOES FROM 11 TO
SEVEN, SO MORE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING IT, AND SURVIVING WITH
IT, NUMBER ONE IT COULD BE THAT
MAYBE THIS VIRUS IS NOT AS
SEVERE, THIS VERSION OF THE
VIRUS IS NOT AS SEVERE AND
NUMBER TWO, YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE
GETTING IT BUT THEY SURVIVE IT
AND THEY ARE IMMUNE TO IT, SO IS
THAT A GOOD THING?
>> WELL A GOOD THING BE NOBODY
GETTING THE VIRUS AND THAT BE
CHINA NOT LYING TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD.
I MEAN THE STUDY SAYS 95% OF
THIS NEVER WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
HAD CHINA NOT LIED.
WELL IT IS HERE NOW AND
SOMETHING WE DIDN’T INVITE HERE.
THE THING WE ARE KNOWING AS THE
AMERICAN INGENUITY WE’RE
TESTING 600,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
MORE THAN 31 MILLION.
NO OTHER COUNTRY CAN DO THAT.
SO AS YOU TEST MORE YOU WILL
FIND MORE BUT WHAT WE’RE ALSO
DOING FROM OUR HEALTH COMMUNITY
AND FROM OUR SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE, WE’RE FINDING BETTER
WAYS OF TREATMENT AND THAT’S
WHAT YOU’RE FINDING HERE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING TREATED
FASTER BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING
TESTED SOONER.
THEY ARE GETTING THE TREATMENT
AND HEALTHIER AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS.
ONE THING ABOUT AMERICA, WE WILL
OVERCOME THIS.
WE WILL FIND A VACCINE, WE’RE
FINDING THERAPIES FOR IT AND WE
WILL ACTUALLY NOT ONLY SAVE
AMERICA BUT SAVE THE REST OF THE
WORLD FROM WHAT CHINA LIED
TO US AND PUT HAVOC AND DEATH
THROUGHOUT THIS WORLD.
STEVE: YEAH, LEADER MAKE CAR
MCCARTHY YOU’VE SAID EVERYBODY
SHOULD WEAR A MASK.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
HE’S MADE IT CLEAR HE DOESN’T
WANT TO WEAR A MASK BUT HIS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYS
EVERYBODY SHOULD WEAR A MASK.
DON’T YOU THINK IT BE A POWERFUL
SYMBOL IF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WOULD PUT ON A
MASK AND UNDERSTAND WHAT SO MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
DOING TO TRY TO SLOW DOWN THE
SPREAD OF THIS THING?
>> REMEMBER, I SAY WEAR A MASK
BUT WHEN YOU SEE ME SPEAK ON THE
FLOOR WHEN NOBODY ELSE IS
AROUND ME, I’M NOT WEARING A
MASK AT THAT TIME.
STEVE: SURE.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT
SPEAK, I THINK THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, I’VE KNOWN THE
PRESIDENT TO HAVE WORN A
MASK AT TIMES AS HE GOES FORWARD
I DO THINK THE HEALTH OF THE
NATION TO MAKE SURE THIS
ECONOMY DOWN THAT IS NOT
THE APPROACH TO TAKE WITH THE
MORE INFORMATION WE HAVE
KNOWLEDGE TODAY, WEARING THE
MASK IS THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO KEEP THIS ECONOMY OPEN
, KEEP US WORKING KEEP US
SAFE, AND HELP US AS WE BUILD
TOWARDS THAT VACCINE WHERE WE’RE
IN A MUCH STRONGER POSITION THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTRY BEFORE.
STEVE: THANK YOU AND LEADER
MCCARTHY, WE ACTUALLY ALL HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK TO GET INTO THIS
BUILDING.
WHEN WE GO INTO THE GREEN ROOM
WE HAVE TO AS WELL SO WE TAKE IT
OFF WHEN WE’RE ON TV JUST AS YOU
DO WHEN YOU SPEAK AS WELL.
I JUST DON’T SEE ANY DOWNSIDE IN
THE PRESIDENT BEING SEEN MORE
OFTEN WEARING IT, IT’S SYMBOLIC,
OBVIOUSLY, IT’S PATRIOTIC
BECAUSE YOU’RE NOT ONLY
PROTECTING YOURSELF, YOU’RE
PROTECTING OTHER PEOPLE.
I’VE HEARD THERE ARE PEOPLE
AROUND THE PRESIDENT WHO SAY NOW
YOU SHOULDN’T WEAR IT, BUT
NONETHELESS, IT BE A POWERFUL
SYMBOL.
>> IT WOULD FOR THE 4TH OF JULY
WE COULD SHOW OUR PATRIOTISM.
STEVE: GREAT IDEA.
AINSLEY: MR. LEADER, STEVE
SCALISE WAS TWEETING OUT SAYING
NANCY PELOSI IS EXTENDING THE
PROXY VOTE AND SHE WAS DOING
IT FOR 45 DAYS SHE STARTED ON
MAY 20 AND FOR FOLKS AT HOME,
SHE’S TELLING THE FOLKS IN THE
HOUSE THEY CAN STAY-AT-HOME
IF THEY DON’T FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING TO WASHINGTON, VOTE FROM
HOME AND PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
COMMITTEE MEETINGS FROM HOME AND
CORRECT ME IF I’M WRONG BUT
THAT’S WHAT IT IS RIGHT?
>> YES, WHAT IT IS SHADOW
VOTING AND GIVING ALL YOUR VOTES
TO NANCY PELOSI SO IF YOU VOTED
FOR YOUR MEMBER OF CONGRESS SHE
OR  HE, THEY NO LONGER HAVE THE
POWER.
THEY TURNED IT OVER TO NANCY
PELOSI.
THEY STAY HOME.
THEY’RE GETTING PAID FOR NOT
WORKING.
CONGRESS IS ESSENTIAL.
WE WORK THROUGH YELLOW FEVER,
THROUGH THE BURNING OF THE
CAPITOL.
AINSLEY: THEY AREN’T EVEN
WORKING THROUGH ZOOM.
BECAUSE A LOT OF COMPANIES ARE
DOING THIS AND REPUBLICANS SAID
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL, STEVE
SCALISE SAYS SHE’S EXTENDING HER
PROXY VOTING SCHEME FOR ANOTHER
45 DAYS, DEMS EXTEND THEIR FREE
PASS TO SKIP WORK ALTOGETHER BUT
ARE THEY NOT WORKING AT ALL?
>> NO, THEY DON’T SHOW UP.
WORK IN CONGRESS MEANS YOU ARE
THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR YOUR
DISTRICT.
THEY HAVE LOANED YOU THE POWER,
THEY HAVE LOANED YOU THE VOICE
SO WHOSE THE VOICE FOR YOU IF
YOU GO TO CONGRESS?
IF YOU’RE NOT VOTING ON THE
FLOOR ANOTHER MEMBER WALKS
UP AND SAYS KEVIN MCCARTHY
WANTED TO VOTE THIS WAY.
THAT’S ALL THE WORK YOU DO.
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE BY PROXY,
YOU HAVE TO SIGN A LETTER THAT
YOU’RE PHYSICALLY UNABLE TO BE
HERE.
WELL WHAT DID WE FIND?
CHARLIE CRIST SAID HE WAS UNABLE
TO COME TO CONGRESS BUT HE GOT
IN THE CAR AND DROVE FOR TWO AND
A HALF HOURS TO TRY TO WATCH A
LAUNCH OF A SPACE SHIP?
THAT’S WHAT HE DECIDED TO DO
INSTEAD OF REPRESENT HIS PEOPLE?
IF YOU ARE NOT ON THE FLOOR, TO
GIVE THE VOICE OF YOUR DISTRICT,
YOU MISSED THE WHOLE OPPORTUNITY
AND THAT BECOMES LAW.
BRIAN:  RIGHT AND IF YOU’RE TOO
MUCH OF A HIGH RISK MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN’T RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
CHINA IN PARTICULAR HAS NOW
PASSED A CONTROVERSY SECURITY
LAW, GOODBYE HONG KONG, WE ARE
WITNESSING THE TAKEDOWN OF THAT
AUTONOMOUS REGION OF CHINA, THAT
DEAL IS DONE, AND WE ARE GOING
TO STOP WITH OUR SPECIAL STATUS
THERE IN RESPONSE, WHAT I FEEL
IS BAD FOR THE PEOPLE OF HONG
KONG.
THEY’RE ESSENTIALLY GOING TO BE
SMOTHERED BY MAINLAND CHAINA >>
IT’S NOT ONLY BAD FOR HONG KONG,
IT’S BAD FOR THE WORLD.
NOT ONLY DID CHINA LIE TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD SO THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
CHINA HAS NOT ONLY LIED TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD THEY PUT THEIR NAME
ON A PIECE OF A PAPER OF A
TREATY OF HOW THEY WOULD HANDLE
HONG KONG FOR 50 YEARS AND NOW
THEY JUST SHOWED THEY WOULD
NEVER KEEP THEIR WORD.
WHEN THEY BUILT THE ISLAND AND
THEY TOLD OBAMA THAT THEY’D
NEVER WEAPONIZE THEM, THEY LIED
THERE TOO.
WHEN THEY STEAL OUR TECHNOLOGY
AND SAY THEY DO NOT, THEY LIE
THERE TOO.
WHEN THEY SEND PEOPLE OVER INTO
OUR UNIVERSITIES AND WE HAVE TO
ARREST THEM WHEN THEY’RE GETTING
ON THE AIRPLANE WITH OUR SECRETS
THEY LIE THEN TOO.
AND THEY LIE WHEN THEY PAID FOR
THE HARVARD PROFESSOR TO
STEAL THE SECRETS INSIDE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT HE WAS
WORKING ON.
BRIAN:  DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TO THE WORLD NOW?
THEY ARE STERILIZING, ABORTING,
AND MAKING THEM USE IUD’S TO
MAKE SURE THAT MUSLIM POPULATION
WITHERS, AS IF THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS THEY SETUP
AREN’T BAD ENOUGH.
WHERE IS THE WORLD COME DEN
NATION THERE AND THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY THERE?
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE THEY
ARE DOING TO AUSTRALIA?
THEY SIMPLY WANT TO KNOW WHERE
DID THIS VIRUS COME FROM?
LET’S FIGURE IT OUT.
THEY ARE PUNISHING THEM TO EVEN
LOOK AT THE INFORMATION.
WHY DID THEY NOT ALLOW OUR
SCIENTISTS TO COME IN AND HELP
CONTAIN THIS?
WHY DID THEY INFLUENCE THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION TO LIE TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD SO
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HAVE DIED?
BRIAN:  WELL WE SHOULD STEP UP
FOR AUSTRALIA AND FILL IN THE
IRON ORE THEY’RE NOT GETTING
AND HELP THEM OUT WITH TRADE.
THEY ARE ARGUABLY OUR MOST LOYAL
ALLIE.
HOPEFULLY THE PRESIDENT WILL DO
THAT.
WE SHOULD ALSO CHANGE OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN WHERE THESE COMPANIES COME
BACK TO AMERICA.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE HAPPENS
JULY 1?
U.S.  MCA.
THE STRONGEST TREATY YOU CAN
SIGN WHEN IT COMES TO NORTH
AMERICA OR  ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD SO IF YOU ARE A
COMPANY INSIDE CHINA AND YOU’RE
THINKING ABOUT MOVING, DON’T
THINK ABOUT VIETNAM.
THINK ABOUT NORTH AMERICA.
I KNOW JAPAN IS RISING AND
MOVING THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN BACK.
WE SHOULD DO THE SAME.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WARNED US ABOUT, NOT AS
CANDIDATE TRUMP BUT AS
CITIZEN TRUMP.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT
THIS IS WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN
THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION IS WHY
HE NEEDS ANOTHER FOUR YEARS.
STEVE: LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
VIEW FROM THE TOP.